j'ai été empoisonnés et ça me tue à
petit feu
on l'appelle le poison des antilles le
chlordécone ce pesticide a été versé
dans les champs de bananes pendant une
vingtaine d'années
c'est un scandale sanitaire en
guadeloupe et en martinique reconnu par
l'état
seulement en 2018 les intérêts
économiques
la logique du fric l'a emporté sur la
logique sanitaire
le chlordécone étaient répandues sur les
champs pour tuer les charançons des
parasites du bananier dans les années 70
il est classé cancérogène possible par
l' oms
les etats-unis ont alors décidé de
l'interdire en 1976 mais en france il a
fallu attendre 1980 trend fini le
chlordécone
mais il persiste dans les sols nous
savons qu'en ce moment il ya des de
stockage de molécules au niveau de nos
sols mais aussi n'ayant pas de labo
pouvoir mesurer les taux de résidus de
pesticides dans pas mal de produits nous
ne savons pas trop quelquefois à akwa
nous expose en 2000 le chlordécone est
dans le viseur des chercheurs il est
relevé en quantité très élevé dans l'eau
au point que la pêche est interdite par
endroits sur l'homme il pourrait être à
l'origine de cancers de la prostate
en guadeloupe il ya un problème vraiment
particulier sur le cancer de la prostate
et qui montre que nous avons trois à
quatre fois plus de cancer de prostate
et qu'en métropole et qu'à l'europe et
qu' un des facteurs incriminé sera
certainement
l'intoxication par les pesticides les
spécialistes parlent alors de pesticides
ils soupçonnent en effet cocktail aucun
produit n'est ciblées en particulier en
2007 en revanche une étude du professeur
belpomme vise clairement le chlordécone
c'est un empoisonnement beaucoup plus
grave que l' affaire du sang contaminé
puisque c'est une population entière on
a empoisonné cette annonce fait l'effet
d'une bombe
mais l'étude est contestée le scandale
du chlordécone tombe dans l'oubli avant
de refaire surface en 2018 lors d'une
visite présidentielle d'emmanuel macro
aux antilles
l'état reconnaît avoir permis l'usagé
d'un produit dangereux ils entament
désormais une démarche de réparation des
ravages du poison des antilles
[Musique]